AI is going to be the biggest shift in
our lifetime there's five major areas
that I think it's going to completely
turn on its head number one is the
nature of work itself the second is how
businesses operate the third is the
economy overall the fourth is how we
interrelate with one another on a
romantic setting how we choose mates how
we seduce how we have sex and finally
the nature of life itself and how it
actually extends to interplanetary life
and whether or not aliens exist here on
Earth I'm not a big hat guy but I think
if you actually think through the logic
there's some really alarming conclusions
that you can come to